[Musik]
die richtigen fragen bei bild und wir
alle sind entsetzt an diesem sonntag
weil diese schrecklichen bilder die
wahrheit zeigen in diesem ukraine krieg
eine neue dimension dieses krieges egal
was sie jetzt gerade zu hause machen
legen sie das zur seite und schauen sie
hierhin das sind kriegsverbrechen in der
ukraine und die welt diskutiert diese
bilder sie werden uns noch einmal
verändern unseren blick auf diesen krieg
unseren blick auf putin wir diskutieren
wie sehr diese bilder auch die politik
verändern werden gegenüber russland in
diesem ukraine kriegt das tun wir in
dieser runde heute abend hier in
bildstock die richtigen fragen das tun
wir mit erik marquardt grüne
europaparlamentarier mit bayerns
innenminister joachim herrmann mit
thomas kutschaty dem stellvertretenden
spd chef und nicola beer der
stellvertretenden vorsitzenden des
europäischen parlamentes
schönen guten abend in allen wir schauen
gemeinsam in die straßen von butscher
dort spielt das heute dort haben diese
kriegsverbrechen stattgefunden schauen
sie zunächst zu beginn dieser sendung
auf diese bilder die wir groß zeigen
wollen die so schrecklich sind dass wir
sie eigentlich im fernsehen nicht zeigen
unter diesem tag aber doch hingucken
müssen ein mann in einen gully gestopft
ein zivilist getötet in den straßen von
butscher eine decke die frauen abdeckt
die der rother nackt liegen offenbar
zuvor vergewaltigt herr kutschaty
beschreiben sie einfach einmal mit ihren
worten was sie dort sehen in den straßen
von butscher es fällt sehr schwer das zu
beschreiben sind grausam entsetzliche
bilder wenn man gefesselte menschen
sieht tot am straßenrand liegen dann ist
das ein entsetzliches verbrechen was
jetzt auch harte reaktionen zur folge
haben muss da darf die welt nicht
tatenlos zusehen dass in
kriegsverbrechen die müssen aufgeklärt
werden vorgänge müssten untersucht
werden und müssen auch angeklagt werden
scheuen sie sich sie waren vorher
justizminister auch scheuen sie sich in
diesen minuten irgendwie noch das wort
kriegsverbrechen das wort völkermord in
den mund zu nehmen das sind
kriegsverbrechen wenn zivilisten
umgebracht werden und so sieht es danach
aus von russischen kräften
offensichtlich beim rückzug in dem
bereich dann soll das ja etwas
hinterlassen das soll angst machen das
soll ein schüchterner mann sieht völlig
unbeteiligte da in dieses kriegerische
geschehen mit ein das sind verbrechen
und die höheren aufgeklärt und auch
angeklagt hermann was sind ihre worte zu
diesen schrecklichen bildern paul
ronzheimer kommt gerade von dort auch
aus dieser stadt und hat uns alle
sprachlos gemacht sind seinen bildern
hermann versuchen sie worte zu finden
die bilder machen deutlich dass es
längst nicht mehr ein krieg soldaten
gegen soldaten ist sondern dass hier in
klaren bruch des kriegsvölkerrechts
offensichtlich von seiten der russischen
armee brutal auch gegen die
zivilbevölkerung
vorgegangen wird und das nicht nur als
sogenannte cholera kollateralschäden
zufällig am rande weil man in die
falsche richtung geschossen sondern dass
ganz offensichtlich ganz gezielt auch
die zivilbevölkerung hier getroffen wird
ermordet wird gesendet wird das sind
wirklich unerträgliches vorgehen und das
muss auch die gesamte weltöffentlichkeit
zur kenntnis nehmen dass sind
kriegsverbrechen und da muss alles dafür
getan werden nicht nur russland davon
abzubringen sondern in der tat auch
deutlich zu machen dass solche täter
auch wenn es irgend geht vor ein gericht
gestellt werden müssen frau bär witali
klitschko der bürgermeister von kiew
spricht heute von völkermord er war
selber dort auch vor ort dorthin putzer
und hat vor diesen an diesen leichen auf
der straße gestanden frau bär machen sie
sich das zu eigen noch dieses wort
völkermord
ich glaube für uns alle ist die
monstrosität dieser taten unbegreiflich
dass dort gequält wird gefoltert dass
menschen hingerichtet werden mit den
händen gefesselt zivilisten das sind
schwerste verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit das sind kriegsverbrechen
die müssen nicht nur jetzt durch die
dokumentation
eben auch dann später eine aburteilung
durch den internationalen
strafgerichtshof zugeführt werden ich
glaube das fordert auch ein sonder
kriegsverbrechertribunal ähnlich wie wir
es bei dem jugoslawienkriege gesehen ihn
haben es ist unfassbar dass die truppen
von putin wohl aufgrund der frustration
dass sie diesen krieg nicht gewinnen
können jetzt derartig gegen friedliche
bevölkerung vorgeht zivilisten
unerträglich und ja in der die
zielgerichtetheit wie das jetzt hier
erfolgt ist das meines erachtens am auf
dem weg hin zu einem verkauf hat also
auf dem weg zu einem völkermord frau
beer die hier ein tribunal fordert herr
marquardt bei uns im studio hier wenn
sie auf diese bilder schauen die erste
reaktion der europäischen union war
heute man werde eine untersuchung von
gräueltaten in den vororten hatte dort
in butter unterstützen also man wird das
genau überprüfen was gibt es noch zu
überprüfen um zum ende zu kommen dass
sich es sich um ein kriegsverbrechen
handelt also was fehlt noch um
juristisch zu prüfen
das ist bei allen dingen die man
vorfindet natürlich so dass man das noch
mal kurz untersuchen kann aber ich
glaube dass hier die untersuchung nicht
im vordergrund steht dann ist es ja
völlig klar was dort passiert ist und
das sind aus meiner sicht
kriegsverbrechen und ich hoffe dass die
schnelle auch konsequenzen haben gibt es
aus ihrer sicht also heute würde so oft
gesagt das ist unvorstellbar in der tat
ist es gar nicht unvorstellbar war wir
haben das immer wieder in den
vergangenen jahren oder jahrzehnten
erlebt wir haben das vor allen dingen
durch die russische armee immer wieder
erlebt sei es in grosny oder in syrien
wir haben das aber auch in srebrenica
erlebt und damals hat es ernste
politische konsequenzen gehabt dieses
massaker dieses verbrechen dort in
srebrenica
gibt es irgendeinen unterschied noch zu
srebrenica herr marquardt
ich will das gar nicht in der form
vergleichen es reicht er sich die bilder
anzuschauen und zu merken dass diese
angriffskrieg von putin eben nicht wie
er behauptet irgendwen befreien soll
sondern er richtete massive gräueltaten
an und es ist auch so dass man dort
sieht einige behaupten ja man müsste
vielleicht sich ergeben man es aufgeben
tote verhindern wenn man sich ergibt
wenn man putin einfach gewähren lässt
dann kommt es zu solchen morden und zwar
massenhaft und deswegen ist es ganz
wichtig dass die ukraine sich auch
verteidigen kann ich frage deswegen
nachts wenn jetzt nicht um die gräuel zu
gewichten um zu sagen das eine ist
schlimmer als das an oder jetzt sind wir
schon auf diesem level sondern weil es
repariert er damals bestimmte sequenzen
hatte und vor allen dingen der grüne
außenminister auf den erfahrungen von
srebrenica damals joschka fischer diese
rede gehalten hat damals wir schauen
noch mal in den ausschnitt von damals 3
1999 als es um den kosovo krieg und all
diese bilder dort unter anderem in
srebrenica auch ging
auschwitz ist unvergleichbar aber im
meer ist er auf zwei grundsätzen nie
wieder krieg nie wieder auschwitz nie
wieder völkermord nie wieder faschismus
beides gehört bei mehr zusammen lebe
freundinnen und freunde
mag war diese rede ist uns allen
weiterhin in den oa noch wenn sie jetzt
schon lange zurückliegt aber sie ist
aktueller denn je
ja das ist eine rede die jetzt schon
länger zurückliegt und natürlich ist es
auch wichtig dass wir nicht alles in
einen topf werfen ich glaube schon dass
es jetzt wichtig ist dafür zu sorgen
dass sich die ukraine verteidigen kann
dann dass es auch wichtig einen kühlen
kopf zu bewahren und ich hals über kopf
zum beispiel dann in eine kriegerische
auseinandersetzung zwischen nato und
russland zu geraten das kann man dann
nicht mehr kontrollieren das kann ein
flächenbrand zufolge haben hier ist
nichts mehr kontrolliert hier ist nichts
mehr kontrolliert hier finden wie sie es
festgestellt haben kriegsverbrechen
stadt und das was wir dort heute gesehen
haben das ist ja sehr sehr sehr
wahrscheinlich kein einzelfall sondern
das war heute so dieser ort ist
vorübergehend befreit von der russischen
armee das heißt dieser ort war in
anführungsstrichen so sicher dass dort
journalisten jetzt hin konnten und das
dokumentieren konnten deswegen haben wir
aus diesem ort diese beweise
genau aber wenn sie nun versuchen zum
beispiel
herbei zu reden oder zu fordern ich weiß
nicht was da ihre position ist dass man
jetzt zum beispiel mit der nato dort
eingreifen müsste dann hat es eben
konsequenzen die vielleicht viel mehr
leid zufolge haben und deswegen denke
ich dass es richtig ist dass man die
ukraine weiter aus stadt wird um sich
verteidigen zu können dass man aber auch
dass mit einem kühlen kopf machen muss
ich kann ich über meine position
sprechen möchte über ihre position
sprechen herr marquardt charlie und über
dieses nie wieder krieg was wir gerade
von joschka fischer gehört haben und was
damals die begründung war genau eben
auch mit waffengewalt dort eigene
waffengewalt anzuwenden im kosovo krieg
das war das entscheidende argument
damals von joschka fischer was ist
dieses nie wieder krieg was wir uns als
deutsche so sehr auf die fahnen
geschrieben haben wert wenn wir diese
bilder sehen in der ukraine wir sind
keine kriegspartei in dieser
auseinandersetzung gleichwohl sind wir
nicht unparteiisch wir stehen an der
seite der ukrainerin ukrainer und müssen
alles tun damit dieses modeln ein
schnelles ende auch tatsächlich hat und
da muss man jetzt sorgfältig schauen was
ist der richtige weg das auch
tatsächlich erreichen zu können es wird
über weitere härtere sanktionen zu
sprechen seien innerhalb der eu das ist
die westliche antwort darauf und es geht
natürlich auch um weitere
waffenlieferungen in die ukraine damit
die menschen in der ukraine die dortigen
sollte hatten sich verteidigen können
das ist die antwort der westlichen welt
auf diese gräueltaten von putin aber
herr herrmann frau bär hermann wenn wir
uns das anschauen dann haben unsere
sanktionen ja bisher diese
kriegsverbrechen zugelassen
nun zunächst einmal muss man feststellen
dass jetzt die russen hier auf dem
rückzug sind ist das ergebnis einer
unglaublich mutigen kampfes der
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer dänin so
wahrscheinlich weder putin noch auch
viele bei uns in europa so zugetraut
hätten das ist wirklich unheimlich
beeindruckend wie hier die menschen in
der ukraine um ihre freiheit kämpfen
und es ist wichtig dass wir zumindest
sie ordentlich ausstatten ihnen helfen
mit der bewaffnung mit der munition und
ich muss schon sagen es ist schön wenn
man da allgemein mehr darüber redet aber
es ist ja offenkundig dass leider die
unterstützung aus der bundesrepublik
deutschland die von seiten der
bundesregierung in den letzten wochen
leider schon etwas unzureichend war da
wurde zwar viel geredet aber bei der
frage was hat denn die bundesrepublik
deutschland konkret in die ukraine
geliefert sind leider die meldungen sehr
bescheiden da wird dann immer alles für
geheim erklärt aber offensichtlich sind
viele andere europäische länder
wesentlich stärkere unterstützung für
die ukraine als das leider die
bundesrepublik deutschland war
beschlagen aber immerhin wenn wir uns
einig sind wir müssen die massive
unterstützen dann ist es gut der mut der
ukrainer ist sehr beachtlich und wenn
ich noch mal sagen darf ein klitschko
von völkermord spricht er dann muss man
natürlich auch die visuelle historie der
ukraine im blick haben denn es hat in
den 30er jahren schon einmal die
situation gegeben dass stalin ganz
gezielt millionen von ukrainer hat
verhungern lassen und zwar ganz gezielt
ihnen das essen weggenommen hat um die
dort verhungern zu lassen und das sind
die erinnerungen die die ukrainer
natürlich auch haben wenn ich jetzt um
diesen krieg geld seitens russland
ski-ass putin für sie der neue stalin
nun das was er jetzt macht ist
inzwischen ja von diesen schrecklichen
diktatoren der vergangenheit kein großer
unterschied mehr wir können hier
überhaupt nicht mehr erkennen dass es
sich um das verfahren eines
demokratischen staates handelt sondern
hier wird in einer brutalen art und
weise letztendlich wieder schlimmer als
den alten sowjet-zeiten agiert und das
ist völlig unerträglich und da ist es
eben auch wichtig dass jetzt wirklich
die weltgemeinschaft deutlich macht dass
sie ein solches vorgehen auf gar keinen
fall akzeptiert es ist ein regionaler
krieg aber es hat eine bedeutung
letztendlich für die gesamte
weltgemeinschaft
ich will noch einmal auf dieses zitat
frau bär von joschka fischer hinaus der
sagt nie wieder krieg und begründet
damit ein eingreifen in einen krieg
stehen wir nicht genau an einem solchen
punkt jetzt dass wir hier schön im
studio schön in deutschland ganz locker
sagen kann das wollen wir gar nicht aber
wir schaffen es halt mit den bisherigen
mitteln ja ganz offenbar nicht die
waffengewalt und diese kriegsverbrechen
dort zu verhindern also bedeutet nie
wieder krieg einfach mehr als tatenlos
mehr oder weniger tatenlos zuzuschauen
vermehren
denke wir sind nicht tatenlos aber ich
glaube wir müssen noch weitere taten
ergreifende müssen die weltgemeinschaft
die ihr leben auch schon erwähnt worden
ist noch strenger um putin herum ziehen
damit er wirklich isoliert ist deswegen
fand ich die ergebnisse des des
eu-china-gipfels auch so enttäuschend
ich glaube man muss jetzt auch den
chinesen klar machen dass sie sich
entscheiden müssen ob sie auf der
richtigen seite der geschichte stehen
bei aller bisherigen nähe auch der
regime
zueinander ich glaube dass die chinesen
diese gräueltaten diese verbrechen gegen
die menschlichkeit diese
kriegsverbrechen nicht mehr akzeptieren
können dass sie ihnen die augen öffnen
müssen putin jetzt auch eben von der
anderen seite von der östlichen seite
her zu isolieren sein system
auszutrocknen ich erwarte umgehend einen
sondergipfel der eu staats und
regierungschefs scheinen die shell der
präsident des rates hat ja heute auch
schon reagiert auf diese kräuter hat es
doch was ein bisschen jetzt weitergehen
bei den sanktionen und wir müssen noch
stärker wir müssen noch stärker die
ukraine an dieser stelle unterstützen
aber das ist jetzt darum die
kriegsverbrechen zu dokumentieren um sie
schnell zu nach zu verfolgen zu können
und gleichzeitig die ukraine noch
stärker dadurch zu unterstützen dass wir
direkt helfen mit finanziellen mitteln
mit waffen mit humanitärer hilfe aber
auf der anderen seite eben auch noch
stärker isolieren also die sanktionen
noch einmal enger ziehen mit
unterstützung auch der länder wie china
wie indien da kann sich jetzt keiner
mehr rausreden keiner mehr rausreden ich
will noch einmal auf diesen punkt herr
marquardt historische verantwortung zu
sprechen zu kommen sie haben sofort
darauf sehr allergisch reagiert und
haben hier unterstellt ich würde jetzt
ein eingreifen dort herbeireden aber die
frage stellt sich doch auch wirklich
moralisch in diesem moment wir schauen
hier auf diese fotos und reden locker in
deutschland über unsere geschichtliche
moralische verantwortung was ist all
dieses gerede sage ich einmal wert von
historischer verantwortung wenn hier
offenbar eine rote linie noch nicht
überschritten ist
es ist ja nicht so dass wir nichts tun
aber man muss eben dann irgendwo auch
sich anschauen welche sanktionen welche
maßnahmen haben welche konsequenzen und
wenn es um überschaubare konsequenzen
gibt und man eventuell mehr leid
anrichtet als das momentan dort zu sehen
ist und es ist ja schon so schrecklich
dann muss man glaube ich wirklich diesen
kühlen kopf wenig geredet habe bewahren
und da können online und genau das ist
ja ein ganz wichtiger punkt können sie
anhand dieser fotos kühlen kopf bewahren
und können sie ganz cool sagen das ist
nicht laut genug da könnte noch viel
mehr leid entstehen und deswegen machen
wir nicht mehr ist bei uns die rote
linie noch nicht überschritten nein ich
glaube niemand sagt dass man nicht mehr
machen kann oder sollte ich bin auch
dafür dass man die sanktion deutlich
verschärft ich glaube auch im
europäischen konnte dass deutschland
dort keine schlüsselfigur momentan ist
bei der härte der sanktionen sondern
eher etwas blockiert und ich denke dass
wir da gemeinsam auf europäischer ebene
schnell dazu kommen sollten also ein
sondergipfel finde ich auch richtig dass
wir besprechen welche zusätzlichen
sanktionen werden oft verhängt aber auch
welche militärischen mittel braucht die
ukraine es fehlt ihnen ja nicht an
soldatinnen und soldaten sondern
ausrüstung welche mittel braucht
eigentlich die ukraine um das vorrücken
der russischen armee aufzuhalten und um
auch eben dafür zu sorgen dass putin
merkt sich ein krieg der lohnt sich
nicht nur nicht sondern er muss dort aus
der ukraine verstanden herr kutcher hat
die zusätzliche sanktionen das geht
bisher aus dem was olaf scholz der
bundeskanzler jetzt auf diese bilder
gesagt hat nicht heraus das liest man
aus seinen worten bisher nicht raus das
liest man aus den worten von annalena
baerbock aus der aussenministerin und
auch des wirtschaftsministers des
vize-kanzlers bei olaf scholz findet
sich nicht das wort kriegsverbrechen in
dem statement und findet sich nicht das
wort härtere sanktionen darüber wird
jetzt innerhalb der europäischen union
zu diskutieren seien aber ganz schnell
auch die nötigen maßnahmen müssen jetzt
getroffen werden das kann nicht ohne
konsequent weil die heißt ein statiker
ist kurz die meisten ja gerade wahlkampf
da geht es ja auch darum klare worte zu
finden wir schauen auf das schlimmste
was wir bisher in diesem krieg gesehen
haben der sowieso schon schlimm war und
dann reicht es meiner ansicht nach jetzt
nicht zu sagen wir prüfen wir laden zu
einem sondergipfel ein wir gucken mal
was ist ihre position im moment reicht
es an sanktionen was wir haben oder muss
verschärft werden es sind diese sanktion
fortlaufend immer zu überprüfen und
jetzt gerade aufgrund dieser bilder die
wir jetzt heute hier sehen ist das jetzt
natürlich ein zeitpunkt wo man die
sanktionen erst recht auf den prüfstand
stellen muss und ich gehe davon aus dass
das auch sehr kurzfristig innerhalb der
europäischen union geklärt wird und ich
halte weitere sanktionen durchaus für
angemessen genauso wie wir auch dafür
sorgen müssen dass die soldaten in der
ukraine weitere waffen bekommen um sich
verteidigen sodass ist wird doch auch
bei ihnen auch wenn es nicht das ein
thema für die landtagswahl eigentlich
ist wird es wahrscheinlich eine der
häufigsten fragen bei ihnen auf der
straße war geht das nicht doch ohne
putins gas ohne putins öl auszukommen
vor dieser frage stehen wir anhand
dieser bilder aufs neue und vitali
klitschko sagt ganz ganz ganz prägnant
ganz konkret keinen einzigen cent mehr
für putin lösen sie das seien kein cent
mehr wir müssen putin möglichst schnell
treffen aber auch wirksam treffen also
noch ist vieles händen wissen wir 19
milliarden wir werden nicht von heute
auf morgen aus der gasversorgung aus
russland eins zu eins aufsteigen können
das wird nicht funktionieren ohne dass
wir erhebliche schäden bei uns auch
tatsächlich haben und dann werden wir
nicht mehr in der lage der ukraine auch
zu helfen in ihren eine art und weise
wenn bei uns die komplette wirtschaft am
boden ich das wirklich sehr anders legen
ist das alles entscheidende jetzt alles
zu tun um so schnell wie möglich vom
rasen verordnung das wissen wir dass die
worte von vier oder fünf wochen würden
sie anders sprechen wenn chemie waffen
zum einsatz gekommen wären wäre dann
eine rote linie überschritten wo man
dann doch den gashahn abdrehte oder was
ist was ist diese rote linie oder gibt
es gar keine rote linie und putin kann
machen was er will wir zahlen weiter für
russisches gas ich glaube wir sollten
uns hier nicht über einzelne
angriffsarten unterhalten der gesamte
krieg ist ein gräuel ist ein grausamer
als ereignis vom ersten toten an ist das
schon ein toter zu viel gewesen und
deswegen muss dieser krieg so schnell
wie möglich beendet werden da ist viel
diplomatie gefordert da müssen wir auch
einmal warten auch nicht über einzelne
ins boot nehmen um dann auch der sohn so
wirksam werden zu lassen doch ich möchte
die leute aus sensation sprechen weil es
mittlerweile nach diesen mehr als fünf
wochen eine andere dimension noch mal
bekommen hat dieser krieg und weil man
sich schon fragt wann es eigentlich bei
ihnen bei der ampel regierung dieser
punkt erreicht um aufs russische gas zu
verzichten weil im moment ist dieser
punkt ja für sie noch nicht erreicht wir
treffen putin viel härter wenn es uns
gelingt in den nächsten monaten einen
weg zur findung dauerhaft aus dem bezug
von energie aus russland aussteigen zu
können das muss das ziel sein drei
monate jetzt nichts zu importieren aus
russland hilft im ergebnis nicht viel
weiter deswegen müssen wir jetzt schnell
von anna zu einer dauerhaften lösung
kommen um keine wirtschaftsbeziehungen
mehr mit russland verlegen zu müssen das
ist das entscheidende das trifft putin
auf dauer viel härter und ist auch eine
größere bedrohung für ihn frau wer das
macht doch was auch wie sie als
politikerin wie sie herr kutcher hat die
sie haben mag was herr herrmann als
politiker in den spiegel gucken müssen
wir wissen doch alle dass das keine
unerheblichen zahlungen sind die an
russland weiter fließen jetzt können wir
im moment uns schönreden dass das nicht
sofort umgemünzt werden kann in panzer
und den raketen und doch zahlen wir für
dieses russische gas und russische öl
jeden tag weiter vitali klitschko sagt
wie gesagt ab sofort kein cent mehr man
kann zu keinem anderen schluss kommen
wenn man auf diese bilder von butscher
kommt können sie noch guten gewissens
frau b diese zahlungen mittragen können
sie noch erklären warum wir millionen
milliarden cents weiterhin nach moskau
überweisen
ich habe das für mich persönlich ja
schon geäußert dass ich finde dass wir
genau diese zahlungen einstellen müssen
dass jetzt auch die nächsten schritte
der sanktionen gegeben müssen gehen
gegangen werden müssen also jetzt eben
auch bei den fragen energie ölimporte
stoppen kohl wir haben ja schritte
ergriffen innerhalb der europäischen
union
einkaufsgemeinschaften zu bilden andere
lieferanten zu finden ölproduktion in
anderen staaten eben zu erhöhen und ja
es wird uns hart treffen aber ich habe
den eindruck aus gesprächen die ich mit
der bevölkerung führe dass hier die
menschen wesentlich weiter sind in
unserer gesellschaft dass sie sagen wir
wollen diesen kriegsverbrecher putin
kein geld mehr überweisen und ich hoffe
dass die äußerungen von dem
ratspräsidenten schein michelle jetzt so
zu verstehen ist dass dies in kürzester
zeit zwischen den mitgliedstaaten
abgestimmt wird wie gesagt das
europäische parlament das sich auch als
vizepräsidentin vertreten ist hier schon
längst weiter und fordert dies schon
seit längerem hermann noch einmal ganz
kurz und klar gehen sie damit also
stoppt sofort auch wenn es uns gewaltige
kosten verursacht und erhebliche
probleme schafft das ist ja völlig klar
aus meiner sicht muss eindeutig die
unmittelbare unterstützung für die
ukraine im vordergrund stehen weil er
die soldaten russland stehen auf
ukrainischem boden ich will diese
wirtschaftsredaktion überhaupt nicht
infrage stellen aber ich habe große
zweifel dass sie putin davon jedenfalls
kurz riesig beeindrucken lässt und das
entscheidende ist dass wir die ukraine
massiv unterstützen mit waffen mit
panzern mit mit munition und zwar sofort
und zwar nicht darüber diskutieren was
die in vier wochen kriegen die brauchen
das jetzt es ist ein mutiges voll ich
bin wirklich beeindruckt davon wie die
überhaupt diesen widerstand organisieren
wie die ukrainische armee unterwegs ist
und die braucht jetzt sofort ihr die
unterstützung damit sie jetzt sich
weiter wehren kann es ist das meine ich
sagen das entscheidende um die russische
armee zu stoppen der markt noch einmal
zum abschluss dieser runde die frage wir
haben nochmal diese fischer rede in den
ohren müsste eine ähnliche berbalk oder
eine ähnliche rede jetzt folgen und ja
unter dem einsatz der ganzen politischen
leidenschaft erklärt werden warum wir
eben auf putins gas verzichten warum die
grünen ein grüner wirtschaftsminister
eine grüne außenministerin jetzt auf
putins gas verzichten kostet das ja was
es wolle also ich habe nicht das gefühl
dass sich die ampel regierung das gerade
besonders leicht macht aber es gibt zum
beispiel experten die sagen wenn wir
jetzt sofort den gashahn abdrehen dann
sind die folgen bei uns relativ hart und
es kann sein dass durch die steigende
nachfrage aus europa die dann mit einmal
auf dem weltmarkt auftritt die gaspreise
so explodieren dass putin am ende mehr
geld hat als vorher und das kann ja auch
nicht das ziel sein ich bin aber total
dabei dass wir sagen wir müssen jetzt so
schnell wie möglich aus diesem gas
aussteigen und wir müssen dann eben auch
die wirtschaftlichen konsequenzen tragen
dafür muss der staat dann eben die
verantwortung auch übernehmen da muss
man dann geld bereitstellen dann ist
eben die schuldenbremse dieses jahr
nicht einzuhalten und im nächsten jahr
vielleicht auch nicht aber wir können
der ukraine nicht erklären dass wir
aufgrund wirtschaftlicher faktoren bei
uns weil wir nicht bereit sind den preis
zu zahlen für das machen wir können und
dass wir aufgrund der folgen jetzt da
einfach zuschauern in der ukraine und
deswegen glaube ich auch dass wir in
diesem bereich deutlich schneller
deutlich weiter gehen sollten und dass
wir auch im europäischen kontext schauen
sollten mit den 27 eu staaten wie können
wir denn dann die folgen möglichst
gering gestalten und können wir auch
wenn es zum beispiel in der industrie
dann zu einbrüchen kann das dann mit
geld ausgleichen dazu muss aber in der
ampel regierung dann auch ein konsens da
sein dass man die wirtschaft nicht
alleine lässt letzte frage an
spd-spitzenmann kutschaty was ist diese
rote linie das würde ich gerne verstehen
was ist die rote linie für putins gas
und was ist die rote linie
möglicherweise auch mit blick auf sogar
ein militärisches eingreifen
ich halte ein militärisches eingreifen
der nato für nicht angezeigt glaube
keiner möchte deutschland möchte die
nato in einen dritten weltkrieg stoßen
und stürzen und das wäre der fall so das
wäre tatsächlich der voll mit
verheerenden folgen auf dem ganzen
kontinent das muss mit allen mitteln
verhindert werden und deswegen geht es
jetzt darum putin in die knie zu zwingen
mit den instrumenten die wir als
friedliche westliche welt haben das sind
die harten sanktionen das sind
diplomatische maßnahmen und dazu müssen
wir jetzt auch die gesamte
weltgemeinschaft ich war nach der roten
jahren auch mitzumachen ich halte auch
nichts davon jetzt über rote linien
hierzu diskutieren und wladimir putin
jetzt sämtliche strategien offenzulegen
die wir jetzt hier auch tatsächlich
haben das ist zwar immer gerne und sehr
schön gesagt und sehr populär auch aber
taktische bringt das uns keinen
zentimeter weiter wenn wir hier über
rote linien sprechen und das würde ihn
mal einhegen man hat einfach den
eindruck er kann tun und lassen was er
will und deswegen finden ja diese krise
verbrechen renterin in butter auch stadt
wir ziehen kurzen strich darunter und
diskutieren hier gleich über das was uns
ebenfalls in deutschland schwer bewegt
wir spüren ganz unmittelbar die
auswirkung natürlich nicht nur beim gas
und bei steigenden preisen sondern bei
mittlerweile hunderttausenden menschen
die infolge dieses schrecklichen krieges
zu uns gekommen sind das gleiche thema
nach einer ganz kurzen pause hierbei
bildet
zurück bei bild die richtigen fragen
heute an diesem sonntag mit erik
marquardt im grünen europaparlamentarier
mit joachim herrmann bayerns
innenminister und im moment chef der
innenministerkonferenz mit thomas
kutschaty dem stellvertretenden
spd-vorsitzenden und nicola beer der
vizepräsidentin des europäischen
parlamentes noch einmal in allen schönen
guten abend herr herrmann wir stehen ja
vor oder mitten in der wohl größten
flüchtlingswelle seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg sind sie im moment wenn man
das überhaupt so formulieren kann
zufrieden mit der organisation mit der
planung mit den regelungen dieser
flüchtlingswelle
zufrieden ist vielleicht zu viel gesagt
aber insgesamt schon zum einen sehr
dankbar für die großartige leistungen
vieler ehrenamtlicher und hauptamtlicher
die hier in den letzten wochen dazu
beigetragen haben dass wir die
flüchtlinge die nach deutschland
gekommen sind bislang ganz überwiegend
gut aufnehmen konnten das läuft muss man
ehrlich sagen obwohl ich in dem kurzen
zeitraum mehr sind als selbst 2015 16 da
im am anfang gekommen sind es läuft
wesentlich besser ich kann für bayern
jedenfalls sagen dass wir überhaupt
niemanden in einem zelt wie wir das
jetzt hier gerade sehen unterbringen
mussten wir haben alle im moment unter
einem
geschlossenen häusern manche
vorübergehend für ein zwei drei tage in
einer sporthalle aber alle anderen dann
den weiteren unterkünften ich sind
insgesamt allein vom erst zugang jahr
deutschlandweit 300.000 schon gekommen
davon 100.000 in bayern angekommen und
wir haben aktuell auf jeden fall schon
rund 60 bis 70 tausend wirklich gut
untergebracht die hälfte vielleicht den
privatunterkünften die anderen in
solchen staatlichen oder kommunalen
unterkünften und das ist schon eine
beachtliche leistung innerhalb von vier
wochen und ich glaube wir müssen damit
nicht zufrieden sein aber wir können
insgesamt schon dankbar dafür sein dass
wir so großartiges engagement und eine
so großartige hilfsbereitschaft in der
deutschen bevölkerung haben immer wenn
ich diese oder eine ähnliche frage
in den wochen gestellt habe antwortet
die politik darauf das ehrenamtliche
engagement erst mal zu loben und mein
eindruck ist dass das tatsächlich das
ist was am allerbesten funktioniert das
was die bürgerinnen und bürger hier im
land machen wie sehr sie sich
tatsächlich engagieren für die
ukrainischen flüchtlinge aber
registrierung hat nicht funktioniert man
weiß gar nicht wie viele ukrainische
flüchtlinge sich auch nur annähernd im
land aktuell aufhalten und die
verteilung funktioniert auch nicht
da bin ich mit manchen dingen in den
ersten wochen in der tat ich zufrieden
gewesen wir haben das ja zum beispiel
beim bund angemahnt dass eine
vernünftige verteilung stattfindet das
ist in der tat leider so dass zunächst
die bundesregierung die
bundesinnenministerium persönlich aber
auch andere mitglieder der
bundesregierung erklärt haben man könne
die gar nicht verteilen weil die völlig
frei sind natürlich sind das freie
menschen und natürlich wenn jemand sagt
ich will zu meinem onkel nach köln oder
zu einem bruder nach paris da dürfen die
darüber halb frei hinreisen aber sobald
sie staatliche leistungen in anspruch
nehmen dann haben wir nach der deutschen
gesetzeslage sehr wohl die möglichkeit
in deutschland zu verteilen deshalb
leider
wenig gedauert so erinnern sich das ja
auch die regierende bürgermeisterin von
berlin fragt natürlich angemahnt hat der
bund muss jetzt dass eine verteilung
vornehmen die können nicht alle in
berlin samt der münchner
oberbürgermeister von der spd hat gesagt
das kann nicht so sein dass die einen
ferrari so in münchen ankommen wir
müssen verteilt werden also ich habe
zwei drei wochen gedauert bis man das in
der bundesregierung kapiert hat jetzt
läuft das einigermaßen mit der
verteilung bei der registrierung haben
wir auch das problem dass hier zunächst
erklärt wort und ist ein nein die bürger
nicht registrieren oder sei eine
zumutung ich sage ganz klar ist aus
sicherheitsgründen unbedingt notwendig
dass alles so schnell wie möglich
registriert werden das ist zu deren
eigenen shops notwendig untersagen
inzwischen auch große karitative
organisationen wie die diakonie
deutschland das ist zum schutz der
betroffenen selbst wichtig dass sie
registriert werden zum beispiel wenn es
um den themen und zwangsprostitution
menschenhandel und dergleichen geht und
es ist aber auch für unser aller
sicherheit notwendig dass ihr wissen wer
eigentlich in unserem land ist und wer
dann sozialleistungen kassieren will
herr kutschaty ihre ministerin und ihre
senatoren und so weiter haben all das
verhindert nein haben sie überhaupt
nicht aber wir haben noch mal mit den
bürgerinnen und bürger aus der ukraine
eine andere rechtliche situation
sie sind eu-bürger sie können ohne visum
sich 90 tage lang in der europäischen
union aufhalten viele sind auch mit dem
pkw gekommen einfach über die grenze und
da können sie nicht alles kontrollieren
es wären sie schon sagt die
bundespolizei und sagte auch joachim
herrmann sie halten nicht einander wenn
einer im privat pkw in die über die
grenze kommt das kriegen sie nicht
kontrolliert sie wollen nicht alle
grenzen dichtmachen innerhalb der
europäischen union ist wird an den
außengrenzen der europäischen union also
an der grenze zwischen der ukraine und
polen genau registriert wer kommt in die
eu und natürlich ist die bundespolizei
in den zügen mit unterwegs und schaut
auch wer da jetzt kommen und wir wissen
schon sehr genau wer jetzt alles kommt
nämlich überwiegend frauen mit ihren
kindern die auch bislang zu einem großen
teil von einigen angehörigen sie sagen
sie wissen genau wer kommt aber sie
haben keine ahnung wie viele kommen das
sind ja so über den daumen gepeilt ja
weil die wir im moment habe ich jede
einreisen kann auch innerhalb der eu
sicher freiberg und weil dann erst
einmal genau wer kommt derweil heute
welche leute wissen das ist zum
allergrößten teil über die kontrollen
dann auch in den zügen von der risiken
dürfen dieses registriert haben da
können sie sagen während denen wissen
werden von denen die wir kontrollieren
können wissen wir dass auch ja aber das
macht ja nicht besser was ich jetzt
gerade sagen wir können nicht jedes mal
ehrlich wo man habe keine ahnung wer
gekommen ist und man hat auch ich doch
doch dort hat er auch stopp stopp stopp
neuer weg werden wir wissen schon von
denjenigen die gekommen sind die sich
registrieren lassen wäre das immer und
haben wissen aber daher haben ganz kurz
zum faktencheck hier in der sendung die
bundesregierung spricht von der aktuell
sehr hohen dunkelziffer das heißt bei
einer dunkelziffer weiß man ja auch also
erstmal gar nicht wie hoch die ist und
man weiß natur gegebener maßen auch gar
nicht ja wer sich dann darunter befindet
das ist ja logisch
es ist in der tat eine absolut
unbefriedigende situation
wir haben in bayern sehr nachdrücklich
darauf gedrungen dass die städte und
landkreise so schnell wie möglich
möglichst viele registrieren möglichst
alle registrieren wir haben aktuell nach
den meldungen unserer städte und
landkreise in bayern schon über
76.000 flüchtlinge in bayern die hier
registriert worden sind das merkwürdige
ist aber dass die bundesregierung sich
das bundesinnenministerium seit drei
wochen weigert und die unmittelbare
auskunft aus dem ausländerinnen
ausländerzentralregister zu geben in
denen diese zahlen eigentlich alle
eingepflegt werden sollten die konkreten
meldungen was auch wichtig ist weil dann
dort nämlich eine automatische abgleich
auch mit dem verhandlungs datenbestand
von kriminellen und dergleichen auf
deutscher und europäischer ebene
stattfindet will man weigert sich und
setzt sie jeweils aktuellen zahlen zu
geben am beginn vor einem monat war das
kein problem da hatten wir einfach das
interesse zu erfahren wo sind denn die
ukrainer die schon lange hier leben im
land weil die dann natürlich die
potenziellen aufnehmer sein könnten für
jemand der private unterkommen wird da
haben wir innerhalb jeweils von 48
stunden alle aktuellen zahlen bekommen
so war das anfang märz seit drei wochen
weigert sich das bundesministerium uns
die jeweils aktuellen zahlen zu geben
damit ich auch überprüfen kann wie viele
sind den tatsächlich jetzt in bayern in
diesem ausländerzentralregister die
bundesregierung weigert sich aus mir
überhaupt nicht nachvollziehbaren
gründen diese zahlen den ländern wie das
übrigens mehrere länder nicht nur bayern
sie auch gelernt haben haben sie sagen
nicht nach weil ich war für ihn das
versuchen wir kurz aufzuklären können
sie antworten warum macht ihre
innenministerin die gesamte registrieren
links regierung wird ja jetzt aufgebaut
das ist das peak system das dauert
leider etwas auch mir zu lange bis das
alles mit der registrierung mit der
eintragung so funktioniert aber ich
möchte an einer stelle sagen dass jetzt
plötzlich registrierung um aller gewalt
ganz sofort und so schnell gefordert
wird nur damit keine sozialleistungen
falsch kassiert werden das im anblick
dieser bilder die wir gerade im ersten
teil der sendung gesehen haben versender
die elemente von jetzt herr maja drei
anlagen das verletzt jetzt natürlich
schon wir haben gerade bilder gesehen
von menschen die brutal umgebracht
worden sind wir erleben menschen die
dafür aber jetzt ist eine interessante
rechnung oder sozialbetrug hier also ich
glaube es geht um die reformierung der
menschen willkommen in der absicht der
sozialleistungen zur kaserne aber auch
wegen ich glaube ganz so hab ich mir den
hermann gerade nicht gut aber was ist
schon ein starkes argument ganz kurz mit
mit herrn marquardt ein entscheidendes
argument hier nicht zu registrieren war
erstmal auch damit würde man die
menschen unnötig drangsalieren die
können sich frei bewegen die können ja
einreisen quasi wie touristen warum soll
man dann kontrollieren an den grenzen
hat aber doch auch zur folge dass man
den menschen in den ersten 90 tagen
überhaupt gar nicht helfen kann wenn man
nicht weiß dass sie hier sind
also erstmal muss man ja sagen der
eindruck der erweckt wird das auch für
mich ein ehrlicher weise die wissen gar
nicht mehr kommt das ist nicht richtig
es gibt europäische fahndungsdaten
banken natürlich müssen die menschen
wenn sie aus der ukraine ausreisen
erstmal aus der ukraine aus reisen da
gibt es checkpoints und dann auch in
einem eu staat einreisen und dort werden
sie kontrolliert dort werden auch die
personalien kontrolliert und dann weiß
man wer in der europäischen union ist
das muss man dann auch nicht mit der
gleichen datenbank zwei stunden später
noch mal in der nächsten grenze machen
aber deswegen ist es so wenn sie es
wissen wie viele ukrainische flüchtlinge
sind aktuell in deutschland das ist in
der tat die frage die nicht gut zu
beantworten ist aber wir wissen
natürlich und man darf jetzt nicht den
eindruck erwecken dass man irgendwie
alle sozialleistungen bekommen natürlich
muss man sich um sozialleistungen ich
glaube dass die aller jährige cynthia
sozialwaisen und es ist auch so dass wir
liegen genau wissen wie viele urlauber
jetzt gerade aus spanien in rumänien
sind wir wissen nicht wie viele
gastarbeiter aus rumänien gerade in
deutschland sind das sind auch keine
besonders interessanten informationen
weil man muss glaube ich beim
wesentlichen bleiben und wenn sie zu
recht einfordern wie sollen mehr für die
ukraine tun dann auch im eigenen land
und zwar in der form dass wir jetzt
nicht mit einmal nebelkerzen werfen und
zu tun als wir gebe es hier irgend ein
sicherheitsrisiko das sicherheitsrisiko
ist in der ukraine und wenn wir schaffen
das jetzt halbwegs unbürokratisch
hinzubekommen dass die menschen vor
diesen kriegen fliegen können dann sind
einen schritt weiter ein mögliches
risiko sprechen wir gleich das habe ich
aber gar nicht benannt sondern mir ging
es um die hilfe dieser menschen ganz
konkret er das spielt sich auch an
unseren schulen hier in berlin gerade
art man muss den menschen so schnell wie
möglich helfen und kann das aber gar
nicht weil die gar nicht festgestellt
worden dass die überhaupt hier sind frau
bär wie es der ihre auffassung ist dass
ihre auffassung von freiheit das man
einmal sagt okay man lässt erst mal
kommen man weiß als staat gar nicht oder
in der eu gar nicht wer sich gerade hier
aufhält wie viele ukrainische
flüchtlinge sind 200.000 oder sind
vielleicht schon 800.000 ist das auch
ihre auffassung von freiheit
also aus meiner sicht muss man erst
einmal festhalten das ja hier einst sehr
gut funktioniert haben was sie als
instrument das erste mal benutzt haben
dass menschen erst einmal einreisen
können dass wir nicht irgendwie an der
grenze menschen aufhalten die vor krieg
vor gewalt die vor verfolgung fliehen
sondern dass sie erst einmal ein reißer
können dann ist natürlich zu einem
späteren zeitpunkt nein aber da an der
stelle wird ja das erste mal überprüft
und da wissen sie dann auch wer sich
insgesamt in der europäischen union
befindet darauf hat der kollege mark
wird gerade schon hingewiesen und das
ist das erste mal dass die eu hier eben
in dieser art und weise gemeinsam agiert
so und jetzt geht es darum weiter
erstens zu registrieren und zweitens zu
verteilen diese registrierung wird ja
jetzt auch im eu kontext abgestimmt
aufgebaut das heißt dass wir auch im
datenaustausch haben zwischen den
mitgliedstaaten wer ist wo und wir
machen angebote weg von der grenze also
aus den anrainerstaaten polen tschechien
slowakei ungarn die alle sehr sehr viele
flüchtlinge erst einmal aufgenommen und
untergebracht haben hin nach deutschland
innerhalb von deutschland aber eben auch
in andere mitgliedstaaten bis hin in die
usa präsident biden hat jetzt gerade
dieses angebot gemacht werden also jetzt
auch schon flüge direkt aus dem grenz
ländern auch aus moldawien eingerichtet
die eben helfen dort vor ort zu
entlasten die menschen zu verteilen
gleichzeitig war ein bisschen rücksicht
auch darauf zu nehmen wo haben sie
verwandte wo haben sie bekannte weil es
eben auch große ukrainische communitys
rüber die verschiedenen mitgliedsstaaten
verteilt bekommen und da finde ich ganz
ehrlich sollten wir die diskussion jetzt
hier nicht zu bürokratisch führen nicht
wieder diese typisch deutsche nabelschau
sondern wirklich pragmatisch zu packen
und es ist doch klar wenn ein kind in
der schule ankommt dass es da
registriert ist oder dass es in dem
moment dann registriert wird auch die
vielen tollen ehrenamtlichen helfer die
wir sehen auch die staatlichen
organisationen die hier unterstützen die
helfen doch dann bei der registrierung
die meisten ämter vor ort haben sich
doch darauf auch eingerichtet haben
entsprechende dolmetscher vor ort fragen
willst du hier bleiben willst du weiter
was momentan der schwierigkeiten macht
und das kann keiner von uns zur zeit
beantworten haben was die menschen
selber ja gar nicht wissen wie lange sie
bleiben werden und überhaupt wollen die
meisten wollten von der grenze geschafft
darüber spreche ich ja gleich ob weit
weg das richtige ja wieder zurückgehen
sobald der krieg vorbei ist nein aber
ich glaube das ist das ist jetzt hier
momentan der lage nicht angemessen der
wir da gerade alle miteinander
europäischen union wie ich finde sehr
tatkräftig begegnen und das sollten wir
doch dann auch gerade angesichts dieser
monströsen bilder aus der ukraine
stärker betonen als ob jetzt hier der
letzte datenabgleich irgendwo nicht
funktioniert hat hermann ist das so herr
marquardt hat ihnen gerade gesagt mensch
also wie können sie angesichts dieser
bilder die wir vor allen dingen von
heute empfangen dort aus butscher vor
sozialmissbrauch waren das war die frage
von herrn marquardt gebe ich noch mal in
zur antwort weiter
das problem ist doch ein ganz anderer
ist offensichtlich hat herr kutschaty
von dem was realität in der
bundesrepublik deutschland diese im
moment in solchen dingen offensiv
ziemlich wenig ahnung die realität ist
dass in der vergangenheit ja sogar
situation gegeben hat wo deutsche
bundesbürger kriminell sich vorgegeben
vorgegeben haben asylbewerber zu sein um
geld zu kassieren auch solche fälle gibt
es wir haben inzwischen die ersten teile
wo jemand mit gefälschten und
rheinischen pässen unterwegs ist und
dergleichen das muss doch kontrolliert
werden es wird doch keinem einzigen
ukrainischen flüchtling verwehrt in
unser land zu kommen das ist ein
übrigens gut organisiertes land die
ukraine das ist nicht mehr wie ein
flüchtling aus dem mittelalter in afrika
oder außenminister auch über dem ns
verbrechen staatswesen gewohnt wir haben
keinen einzigen wir haben ich habe
keinen einzigen ukrainischen flüchtlinge
in bayern erlebt er ein problem damit
hatte dass er sich entsprechend
registrieren lassen soll dass er seinen
pass vorliegt oder die gleichen die
menschen selbst haben überhaupt keine
probleme es ist ein problem der politik
wenn etwas schön in berlin die dafür
zuständige sozialsenatorin erklärt hat
die anzeige ist völlig überlastet dann
wurde angeboten dass die polizei hilft
bei der registrierung dann hat katja
kipping von der linkspartei erklärt das
sei
den flüchtlingen nicht zuzumuten dass
sie von der polizei entsprechend
registriert werden was ist das für ein
staatsverständnis was ist das für ein
polizei verständnis
die haben gerade geladen als ein herr
meiningen beispiel ist
die deutsche politik herr marquardt nein
ich finde einfach ganz generell wir
müssen uns auch mal ein bisschen an die
eigene nase fassen also wir können uns
auch hier sitzen ja hier in der bild
-zeitung mal an die eigene nase fassen
die wurde eigentlich in den letzten
jahren berichtet welche schwerpunkte
wohnen gesetzt und da gibt es zum
beispiel studien dass 79 prozent der
berichterstattung über zuwanderung
negativ ist ja und in der bild zeitung
das ist aber auch so ist das zum
beispiel über straftaten von
asylsuchenden von geflüchteten 30 mal
häufiger in der zeitung berichtet wird
als es im statistischen anteil
entspricht an der kriminalstatistik und
diese zahlen kann man ja dann auf sich
wirken lassen was dabei am ende glaube
ich rauskommt ist dass man natürlich
über einzelfälle reden kann dass man
gucken kann die kann man die aufarbeiten
aber man muss auch den blick für das
ganze mal wieder haben wir haben jetzt
eine unglaubliche situation in der
ukraine wir haben aber in der
europäischen union auch eine situation
in der wir wirklich mehrere millionen
menschen kurzfristig aufnehmen müssen
und das auch können man hat in den
vergangenen jahren den eindruck erweckt
das boot ist voll ich saß ich im
november wo sie gleich gesagt haben eine
neue flüchtlingskrise über 1000 am tag
aus belarus und so weiter da wird
manchmal so eine krise bei geredet die
wir glaube ich simuliert haben in den
letzten jahren wir haben viele
möglichkeiten jetzt muss man sich mit
der neuen situation abfinden leider und
das ist bei joachim herrmann ja auch so
dass die cdu/csu lang in der regierung
war leider haben wir nicht die
strukturen um sehr schnell auf solche
großen flüchtlingszahlen reagieren zu
können das muss man jetzt eben
nacharbeiten aber da finde ich ist jetzt
ein parteipolitisches ping pong was da
katja kipping wer sagt wie wo was nicht
so richtig wichtig joachim herrmann hat
glaube ich in bayern genug zu tun und
ich wünsche ihm dabei viel erfolg und
ich hoffe auch dass in berlin das bald
dann gut läuft ich staune gerade wie sie
darauf reagieren wir saßen tatsächlich
zuletzt ende vergangenen jahres hier wir
hatten in diesen tagen als wir damals
zusammen saßen tatsächlich eine massive
flüchtlingskrise die hat sich vor allen
dingen dadurch ausgedrückt dass da
tatsächlich tausende am zaun zur eu
tanten und das sich an diesem zaun ein
wahres drama abgespielt hat das haben
die bilder von damals ja auch
transportiert und wir haben damals ganz
sachlich darüber diskutiert wie der eu
handeln muss und sie hat infolgedessen
ja auch gehandelt dort an diesem zaun
von polen nach belarus damals sie haben
uns vorgeworfen probleme zu benennen in
diesen flüchtlings dass sich die seite
geworfen dass die aufgabe der
journalisten l aus weiter bleibt wie vor
missstände immer missstände auch zu
benennen war und ist es die frage das
ging übrigens gerade von beiden herren
minister aus und nicht von der bösen
bild -zeitung bayerns innenminister hat
gerade gesagt und das lassen sie uns das
ganz nüchtern hier analysieren oder
diskutieren ob das der fall ist dass es
massenhaft bereits nicht nur in
einzelfällen einen missbrauch gibt von
menschen die diese flüchtlingsbewegung
aus der ukraine für ihre zwecke
ausnutzen illegal ausnutzen das war ein
vorwurf gerade von bayerns innenminister
lk die ist dass ihr eindruck in
nordrhein-westfalen aktuell ich bin erst
mal ziemlich entsetzt von der äußeren
von hermann wir sehen diese grausamen
bilder und er spricht jetzt als erstes
hier von missbrauch und sozialmissbrauch
ist ja auch vorhin von ihnen genannt
worden ich will es noch mal sagen ohne
registrierung gibt es auch keine
sozialleistung was soll da missbraucht
werden also das geht ja hinten und vorne
nicht auf als der kollege hermann da
gerade gesagt hat wenn man registriert
jetzt muss man auch genau sagen wo man
herkommt wer man ist und dann ist es
auch völlig richtig dass man anspruch
auf die entsprechende leistung hat auf
unterkunft die kinder in die schule
gehen können oder in die kita das wollen
wir alles auch organisieren und wollen
wollen wir organisieren ist ein ist ein
starkes wort nach so vielen wochen wir
machen einmal den praxistest bei ihnen
im land und wir gehen zu erik lierenfeld
dem bürgermeister von dormagen ich grüße
sie herzlich herr dormagen jonglieren
feld wir haben vor drei wochen
miteinander gesprochen und da waren sie
schon mittendrin in ihrem flüchtlings
engagement dort in dormagen sie haben
sehr früh damit angefangen sie haben uns
damals berichtet dass ihnen am
rosenmontag klar wurde was das bedeutet
auch für ihre stadt aber für ganz
deutschland das haben sie mit ihrer frau
erst mal besprochen und dann haben sie
im krisenstab dort eingerichtet und ganz
konkret angepackt sie haben hunderte
flüchtlinge dort sehr schnell
aufgenommen und versorgt und sie haben
gesagt mensch
für mich alleingelassen hat sich das
geändert
ja erstmal schönen guten abend zusammen
also so richtig geändert hat sie es
nicht außer dass die zahl der menschen
die zu uns kommen sich nochmal weiter
erhöht hat inzwischen haben wir deutlich
über 600 menschen allein in dornwang
untergebracht davon zwei drittel privat
untergebracht da bin ich sehr dankbar
dass es da viele menschen gibt die da
die bereitschaft haben auch die
ehrenamtler die uns unterstützt haben
aber leider gibt es immer noch
insbesondere von unserem land keine
klare aussage was die finanzierung
angeht und da bin ich leider gebranntes
kind weil ich bin schon ein bisschen
länger bürgermeister und zuletzt bei der
letzten flüchtlingskrise ist auch die
kosten erstattet am ende sind wir sehr
viel geld übrig oder auch sehr viel geld
hängen geblieben weil das einfach mal
vergleichen wir haben dann darüber
gesprochen dass allein die gelder die
uns nicht weiter gereicht worden sind
für die menschen die geduldet sind uns
allein in der stadt dormagen knapp 1,5
millionen euro gekostet hat die wir
selber aus dem städtischen haushalt
finanzieren mussten das ist quasi meine
musikschule um eine stadtbibliothek die
jahreskosten haben und das ist leider
immer noch so der punkt dass wir da
wenig unterstützung haben da würde ich
mir auch wünschen dass den worten taten
folgen
es ist die rede gewesen von dass man
jetzt einen stapel außergewöhnliche
ereignisse aus setzt auch davon habe ich
noch nichts mitbekommen wir wünschen uns
dass wir bei der beschaffung von dingen
unterstützt werden auch da gibt es
bisher nicht viel mehr außer ein paar
worthülsen das muss man leider hat es
sehr deutlich so sagen frau bär ihre
farbe stellt den bundesfinanzminister
können sie versuchen herr lierenfeld
eine antwort zu geben warum dauert so
was so lange das heißt man bestraft auch
diejenigen die sich engagieren die
sofort und so war es bei herrn
lierenfeld in dormagen der war noch gar
nicht genötigt dazu der hat wirklich den
finger gehoben und hat in dem moment
entschieden wir werden aktiv in unserer
stadt und sind vor allen dingen
beeinträchtigte menschen die ihr
aufgenommen hat zwei sich in dormagen
also eine ganz besondere aufgabe warum
wird er dann allein gelassen warum hat
der finanzminister gemeinsam mit den
ländern dass sich längst abgeräumt und
seine finanzierungsfrage geklärt
also das ist genau der das ist genau das
was ja vor ort wir an vielen stellen
beobachten dass die menschen einfach zu
packen das einfach geholfen wird über
die kommunen aber auch sehr viel
ehrenamtlich und es ist ja jetzt auch
die entsprechenden dann nach laufenden
finanzierungen sind geklärt worden wir
haben von der europäischen union aus
klargemacht dass sämtliche
regionalisierung und kohäsion smitten
genutzt werden können ob das der
europäische sozialfond ist ob das die
regional mittel sind sämtliche fonds
eben entsprechend genutzt werden können
dass sie verorten nicht mehr finanziert
werden müssen und der bund ist mit den
ländern ja darüber übereingekommen hier
auch entsprechend mit zu unterstützen
das wird jetzt über die länder
entsprechend ausgeschüttet also deswegen
klar das anpacken ist sofort notwendig
die finanzierung kommt dann hinterher
aber diese zusätzlichen mittel werden
entsprechend auch der gravität der täter
also neben es dann hinterher das ist ja
schöne gute sind jetzt wochen
mittlerweile wie gesagt wir hatten uns
zuletzt vor drei wochen ihr gesprochen
mit all ihren fällt da hat er das schon
massiv kritisiert konnte nicht verstehen
wie er auf der alle geld so lange sitzen
bleiben kann überhaupt wieder so lange
allein gelassen werden kann damit herr
herrmann können sie das einmal erklären
wieso was so lange liegen kann und frau
bär sagt jetzt erklärt sich schon alles
in den nächsten tagen realität ist doch
die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hat das
im ersten anlauf nicht abgeräumt das
dauert jetzt nochmal bis donnerstag da
versucht man diesen soft irgendwie zu
klären
in der tat das ist absolut
unbefriedigend
ich kann darin bürgermeister da auch
sehr gut verstehen wir haben in bayern
schon seit etlichen jahren die regelung
dass ist die pauschale zusage des
freistaats gegenüber allen kommunen in
bayern gibt das auf jeden fall der
freistaat denen die kosten
erstattet so dass das restrisiko wie
viel kriegen wir am schluss vom bund
allein der freistaat trägt in anderen
bundesländern ist das aber anders da
haben jetzt in der hand die kommunen im
moment das risiko dass sie immer noch
nicht wissen wie viel sie dann
eigentlich ja so ist es beim er diese
schaltungen bekommen und das ist das was
ist das unbefriedigende das in der tat
zwar bei allen anderen dingen als ein
jahr sind es schon soweit und wir sind
schnell vorangekommen und darzustellen
geholfen werden aber bei der frage wie
viel ist der bund bereit zu zahlen er
könnte ja zum beispiel einfach sagen die
regelung in der letzten drei jahre
werden einfach zu 100 prozent
fortgesetzt werden glaube ich hier alle
länder mit einem solchen sogenannten
flüchtlings aus schaden dass der
bundesfinanzminister und der
bundeskanzler nicht bereit ist einfach
zu sagen die leistungen des bundes wie
in den letzten drei jahren dann
fortgesetzt leider und darüber streitet
man sich immer der klinik das heißt sie
sind genauso unzufrieden mit dem
finanzminister und ihrem bundeskanzler
nein ich kann herrn herrmann uhr
unterstützen bei der aussage dass die
nordrhein westfälische landesregierung
ihre kommunen nicht ausreichend
absichert das was herr herrmann für
bayern macht auch landesregierung zu
sagen den kommunen wir deckeln das www
greifen das auf wir sorgen dafür dass
ihr nicht sitzen bleibt auf den kosten
genau das erwarte ich auch von einer
nordrhein westfälischen landesregierung
genauso wie die nordrhein westfälische
landesregierung auch mehr unterstützen
muss mit mehr erstaufnahmeeinrichtung
sind aber die anderen eine kürzung das
mit leichtverletzter greifen nur das auf
was er sagt ich hab ja wenn ich immer
unterstützen kann bei einer aussage da
ist tatsächlich ein defizit in nordrhein
westfalen ministerpräsident ihrem
präsidenten kommen am donnerstag dieser
woche noch mal genau sagen die konkreten
fort und da gehört darum die
finanzierung sicherzustellen dass die
kommunen nicht auf den kosten sitzen
bleiben der bund hat bereits angekündigt
die kommunen finanziell zuerst
zu halten in dem bereich das muss über
die länder verteilt werden weil die
rechtsbeziehungen laufen immer über vom
bund über land zur kommune das geht
nicht direkt und deswegen ist es wichtig
dass aber auch die länder jeweils eins
zu eins die gelder vom bund weitergeben
an die kommunen da hat ja lierenfeld
auch völlig recht da ist noch ein
offener deckel von der landesregierung
in nordrhein westfalen gegenüber den
kommunen in nordrhein westfalen aus er
an hatten offenbar deckel sagte
kutschaty bei ihnen riesiger offener
betrag wenn wir das hier zu hören und
sortieren noch einmal licht ins dunkel
herr lierenfeld was konkret was muss
konkret auf den tisch was muss konkret
gelöst werden für sie bei dieser der
bund länder konferenz wo es dann ums
geld um die kohle geht
ja es muss klar sein dass wir in den
kommunen wirklich nicht auf dem geld
hängen bleiben dass kein geld unterwegs
verloren geht weil das wasser sich auch
2018 schon so dass der bund finanzmittel
zur verfügung gestellt hat und dann hat
das land gesagt haben ja selber auch auf
wände und die sind dann da hängen
geblieben das halte ich für ein problem
mir ist wichtig dass wir nicht mehr herr
darüber diskutieren über pauschalen
sprechen ja also in nordrhein-westfalen
kriegen sie wo man 10.500 euro pro jahr
für einen menschen den sie unterbringen
und sie müssen sich jetzt vorstellen
wenn ich jetzt nur feldbetten den lander
hinstelle ja wie wir das am anfang auch
gehalten dann kriege ich das hin mit
10500 euro wenn ich den menschen aber
ein bisschen privatsphäre schafft ja wir
haben wirklich keine räume gebaut auch
in turnhallen ja so dass die menschen
die möglichkeit haben sich
zurückzuziehen gerade weil wir eben hier
viele eigentlich nur mütter mit kindern
haben wenn wir dann nachher das problem
dass wir dann auf geld sitzen bleiben
das darf nicht sein das heißt es muss
klar sein dass wirklich die kosten die
uns entstanden sind übernommen werden
denn ich sage das nochmal deutlich bund
und länder haben hier schon millionen
und abermillionen gespart durch die
vielen vielen ehrenamtlichen menschen
vor ort wir haben hier gruppen gehabt
jan tausende von stunden ehrenamtlich
gearbeitet
wir haben viele firmen gehabt die uns
material gespendet haben also das heißt
man braucht nicht die befürchtung haben
dass irgendwo in den kommunen zu viel
geld ausgegeben wird das gegenteil ist
der fall und ich bitte darum dass die
länder noch mal deutlich machen dass wir
uns auch direkt unterstützen indem sie
uns bei der beschaffung helfen weil es
kann ja nicht sein dass 396 kommunen in
nordrhein westfalen jetzt selber gucken
müssen wo sie irgendwelche
container oder ähnliches herbekommen das
muss doch immer mal zentral durchs land
gestört wer also plant die vorderen
klare konkrete forderungen aus dormagen
dort herzlichen dank herr lierenfeld das
nebenher kutschaty das nimmt herr
marquardt das nimmt auch frau bär über
herrn lindner und das nimmt vor allen
dingen joachim herrmann mit über markus
söder danke ihnen dafür letzte frage
hier im studio auch an sie herr
marquardt meine erfahrung ist bei all
denen die zu uns gekommen sind man hört
immer wieder natürlich wollen die so
schnell wie möglich zurück aktuell für
schulkinder bedeutet das ganz oft sie
versuchen auch im moment sich noch ja
die bildung aus der heimat zu holen über
video calls usw wie soll man aktuell mit
den kindern vor allen dingen umgehen
sollen die so schnell wie möglich in die
schule gehen so schnell wie möglich
deutsch lernen oder soll man denen die
möglichkeit geben was vor allen dingen
wladimir klitschko hier im studio gesagt
hat so schnell wie möglich zurückkehren
zu können zu ihren vätern
ich glaube dass es grundsätzlich jetzt
nicht darum gehen kann dass man in drei
wochen mit der situation jetzt beim pisa
test gut abschneidet und alle ganz viel
lernen aber wir müssen natürlich schauen
das sind vor allem alleinerziehende
mütter und väter sind in der ukraine und
die kinder müssen natürlich einen alltag
haben wenn sie dabei noch deutsch lernen
das ist super wenn sie dann in der
schule vielleicht auch sind und die
mütter sich mal einfach auch mit anderen
sachen beschäftigen können als mit der
kinderbetreuung den ganzen tag da darf
man jetzt nicht auf die bremse bei der
integration
drücken weil wir uns alle zusammen
wünschen dass die menschen schnell
zurückkommen können sondern ich glaube
dass es ganz wichtig ist auch damit man
eben keine ja so traumatischen
erfahrungen hier hat dass man möglichst
viel verarbeiten kann dass man sich auch
mal ablenken kann dass man eben
schnellstmöglich die angebote nutzen
kann reise mail oder aber sind das ist
ja eine ganz wichtige frage wenn wir auf
das ziel gucken und wenn wir realistisch
sind vor allen dingen wenn wir die
bilder aus der ukraine sehen von dieser
massiven zerstörung auch von der
traumatisiert traumatisierung dieser
menschen ist es überhaupt realistisch
dass diese menschen
zurückkehren werden oder werden wir uns
darauf einstellen dass das alles
menschen sind die jetzt gekommen sind
auch wenn sie erst mal nicht wollen um
zu bleiben ich wünsche mir dass die
menschen schnell zurück können natürlich
aber wir haben auch in syrien
beispielsweise gesehen ab 2011 die man
am anfang dachte ja irgendwie wird ja
krieg schon schnell vorbei gehen dann
werde ich jetzt in jordanien libanon
türkei vielleicht erst mal in einem
zeltlager und da kommen aber irgendwann
geht es schon vorbei und ich gehe zurück
und jetzt sind wir eben elf jahre danach
immer noch in der situation wo man nicht
nach syrien zurück gehen kann ich hoffe
das wird mit der ukraine nicht so seien
insbesondere weil der präsident ja auch
demokratisch gewählt ist die regierung
demokratisch gewählt ist und nicht das
eigene volk ins zielfernrohr nimmt
deswegen glaube ich dass es da natürlich
möglichkeiten gibt und dass auch der
krieg schneller vorbei ist aber ich
glaube man sollte einfach damit rechnen
dass man eben nicht immer glauben kann
morgen wird schon irgendwie besser
werden sondern dass man realistisch
darauf blick ganz schnell versuch ja
oder nein wladimir klitschko der hier
auf dem stuhl saß vergangene woche der
gesagt hat die wollen nur nach hause ist
das realistisch dass sie schnell nach
hause kommen ja oder nein ich befürchte
nicht wenn ich mir die bilder anschaue
wird das länger dauern ich wünsche es
allen allerdings dass sie schnell zu
ihren familien zurückkehren er hamann
ist das realistisch an ganz schnell es
nach hause kommen all dieser millionen
flüchtlinge ja oder nein
wir dürfen diesen flüchtlingen
jedenfalls die hoffnung darauf nicht
nehmen aber müssen ihnen gleichzeitig
eine optimale integration in unserem
land anbieten vbr ja oder nein
nein es wird länger dauern als sie
denken aber deswegen müssen wir beides
anbieten sowohl beschulung vor ort als
auch digitale möglichkeiten nach hause
und das sehe ich in vielen schulen wir
braten dürfen hier keine verlorene
generation entstehen lassen danke
herzlich für diese runde bild die
richtigen fragen am sonntagabend dank
herr lierenfeld dank herr marquardt der
hermann frau bär und herkunft
[Musik]